No. Are you going to play cyberpunk 77? Uh, only if I got a PS five,
you can't play it on this. I think you can, but I want to experience it for,
you know, I, the way it was supposed to be intended,
it was attended on the PS five. I think so. Yeah.
So I can't download it on this. Probably. You probably can just lower quality.
Oh. Because I want to play it tomorrow. You probably can. I've been playing.
I've been waiting 14 years for it. 14. Yeah. I was the last cyber punk. No,
they've never made one before. It's an exaggeration 14 years.
No, but they've been like, you know what I mean,
saying that it was going to be released last year and this and that.
It's been like, Reeves is in it. Uh, I love him.
I love like my new thing where it's like,
I really do a good job pretending to care.
That's something I'm working on. You don't care about cyber.
How have I been every time you've been telling me about your, your victories.
But when you're doing it though, I understand what you're doing.
And I appreciate it, the effort. So when I talk to her, I got she'll go like,
said like I'll be done with war zone and she'll do something.
Say something ridiculous. Like how'd you do, babe. Right?
Which I know she doesn't give a. It's friendly. It is friendly, but I don't.
But it gives me the opportunity to at least say to somebody,
you know what I mean about the excitement of winning.
Cause I knew it matters to you. And I also genuinely want to gauge your mood.
If it's like we won, then I know it's like, Oh,
we're going to cuddle and watch movies all night.
And also the what drives her crazy. The worst is showing her the wind.
I hate it. I love.
And I had to sit there for like 22 minutes,
just like Steve Dylan and him like scream.
And it's like, I don't.
Oh my God, there was this one game. I'll tell you.
You're a hero, Bob.
I know.
No, my brother will make me cry. I believe my brother will go. Like,
like Bob, I just want to say that I've never been more proud of you.
And I just think that like, you know,
you've improved and you're like a real warrior and it, it just, and, and,
and in my mind, I'm like, okay, Bob, he's 19, he's 20 years old. Right.
When I know that he's, you know, what is he now? 47. Wow.
He's 47 years old. 46. Are you still excited in your mind? He's 19. Really?
In my mind, I got it. He's 19. He's 20, you know what I mean? But he, uh,
he gets really emotional. He gets me all emotional about it. You know,
it's our way to bond. Why not? You know? Yeah. But so cyber punk, uh,
she, she feigns, you know, why not? Why not? Yeah. Here's an opportunity though.
She said she does play a game called among us. So, and you know what,
I will play it. And I would like to engage and play with her.
There was this other game that we're playing like that, um, finding the number,
that one again.
But those are those, aren't like actual what's there like puzzle games.
Juliana is playing for Lawrence.
Is it Oh, wrong and passes, Valor rent.
[inaudible].
Can I just say this though is look at a show like Queens gambit
and we've watched two episodes that I love the show. She seen the whole thing.
Have you seen it? No.
Or I started that and I was a little bored at the first episode. So.